Last time I met astronauts, Jessica Marie.
She was training for her expedition to the international space station.
Seven weightless months later,
she returned on the 17th of April to the same planet,
but a different world.
Jessica. Welcome back.
Dude. Um, you've been now seven months in Orban.
Is it the same Jessica that came back?
I'm not sure.
I think one of the biggest things that still feels a bit odd is that we've come
back to a completely different planet. So whether or not I've changed,
I'm not sure because everything feels completely different.
Given the earth that I came back to.
You came back, you landed on April 17th.
That's not a little more than two weeks ago. Uh, tell that,
tell me about that descent. How was that?
It was really good, phenomenal experience.
I've heard it described many times from my colleagues and of course we get a lot
of training on it as well. So we feel quite prepared knowing what to expect.
And it was such an extraordinary experience because everything was like
clockwork.
And it's really a Testament to how robust that Soyuz spacecraft is exactly when
I expected things to happen. You know, cause really as the crew,
the commander and myself and the left seat as a copilot,
we're monitoring everything throughout the descent.
If things are going nominally, as we say, if things are going well,
then you really don't have to take that much actual action.
You're really monitoring things. You are sending some commands,
but you don't have to do too much if the automatic systems are working well.
But of course we are trained to react to an emergency in which we do need to
take some more action, but it was so interesting to see. I mean,
everything was just happening, like clockwork, exactly what I expected it.
I would be monitoring and there it was.
And then you could really have a sense of how dynamic everything was when you
felt the separation of the upper, the habitation module.
That's on the upper part that actually burns up in the atmosphere and only the
descent module comes down. You could hear those they're pirate,
bolts that fire in order to separate those two parts of the vehicle,
you could hear it and you could feel it, you know, click, click, click,
and inches away from my head. I'm watching the flames, you know, come past.
And it was just a really, really incredible experience.
And then when the parachute opens, that is the most dynamic phase of the flight.
And I was prepared for this because everybody had told me about it,
but nothing can really prepare you for what it feels since it's nothing like
anything I've ever experienced. It's not as if you're swaying,
when the risers come out,
you're it's really motion and everything in every direction as the vehicle
stabilize, it's under the parachute.
So you feel as if you're in a washing machine or something, every,
every motion you can imagine is imparted on your body.
And then that only lasts, lasts for a short time.
Then you're falling under the parachute and you're then closely monitoring
because you want to be completely still and have all of your very tight and be
ready to brace for the impact of the landing itself. And that I had,
it had been described to me as feeling like a car crash.
Since of course you come to a sudden stop,
you have these soft landing thrusters, that fire, and then you hit the ground.
So I was prepared for a really jarring impact. You know,
we have had some experiences where crew members will even get injured because
they don't have their seatbelts tight enough or a limb comes out,
a knee comes out or something.
So I was making sure that I was really well positioned.
So I was expecting this big jarring impact.
And actually I felt like it was quite soft.
They call it a soft landing and then suddenly we're on the ground.
And that was just such a strange experience. You know, you're, you're in space,
you've been there for seven months and the suddenly you're back on the ground in
a field in the middle of Kazakhstan.
I mean, you're trained for this. You, you, uh, probably won't throw it up,
right. But I guess.
It depends, you know, a lot of that is really individual. So some individuals,
even astronauts and cosmonauts do still get quite sick and coming back because
as you might imagine,
your neuro vestibular system has become accustomed to micro gravity and here on
earth, really our,
our vestibular systems have evolved and are very gravity dependent in terms of
your stability, your spatial awareness. It's more than that. For me,
it's just a strange feeling of everything feels so heavy.
Your body feels so heavy. You just feel like you're being pulled down.
And that, that is actually, I still feel like that a little bit,
even a couple of weeks in,
I went for a run today and I'd been doing some running.
We have two hours of reconditioning every day with our trainers in the gym.
And I'd been doing some running on the alter G treadmill that we have,
which is basically sports teams have them for rehab.
You have a little skirt on and it blows air up.
So it offset some of your weight. So I've been running on that a little bit,
but today I ran outside in the heat and Houston with my hundred percent body
weight. And I can say it felt like about 310% body weight because you're,
you're just not used to that.
I think the motor neuron connection as well as is all altered still from
microgravity.
Your new normal is, uh, is the, the weightless, uh,
the weightless life.
Yeah, at least for a little bit longer until my body kind of reintegrates.
And it's really interesting because we spend so much time exercising on orbit in
order to maintain our bone density and muscle mass.
And we spent two and a half hours of our day lifting weights and then doing
cardiovascular exercise, like running or bicycling.
And so you're in really good shape, better shape than when you left.
I'm lifting way more weight than when I left. I have higher muscle mass,
but there's something else going on with the cardiovascular dynamic that
running. It's a very strange thing.
And I think it's partially the motor neuron connection as well from your brain
because, you know, I would feel like I'm lifting my legs, but what I,
what I felt like I was doing in my brain didn't feel the same way in,
in my muscle. So it's really interesting to see that transition.
And that's the kind of thing actually running is the one thing that seems to
take the longest to come back.
It's only when you,
when you had land and then you were in Kazakhstan,
how soon did the Corona situation become
reality for you?
Yeah, very soon,
because as soon as the hatch was open and what happens is the search and rescue
teams come,
they actually open the hatch and we just kind of stay where we are and wait for
them to come in and essentially pull us out.
They don't want us to overexert ourselves when we first land.
And it was apparent from the very moment the hatch was open because everybody
that we saw was wearing masks.
I mean, I understand that your immune system is weakened, right?
Yeah, that's right. That's one of the hallmarks physiologically of space flight.
We do see this dysregulation of the immune system where we have a decrease in
our T-cells. For example, we have sometimes astronauts experience,
reactivation of latent viruses, like the chicken pox virus.
There's something about the microgravity environment,
whether it's the stress or other factors that do cause a dysregulation of the
immune system. So they want it to be extra cautious with us,
given the situation with COVID-19 to make sure that we didn't contract it right
away,
because they weren't so sure how our immune systems would be able to respond to
it. Luckily those things actually do come up quite quickly.
And so that's why they kept us in quarantine for a week.
They were monitoring parameters like our T-cells in order to see how,
how quickly those systems were coming back.
And they did come back to baseline levels within a week.
But it is it's the ISS itself.
Is that a virus free environment? Totally.
It is. Yeah.
We really aren't exposed to any viruses for the entire duration that we're up
there, which is a wonderful thing.
It was wonderful to never worry about having to get a cold or anything like
that. You know, of course.
Well, people are coming. I mean, they're, you,
you have all their El students coming, coming in while you were there. Right.
Right. That's right.
But one of the ways that we try to get around that is that we do have a
quarantine period before launch. So before I launched in Kazakhstan,
for example, we were in a quarantine for about two weeks before launch.
So that's what they try to always do. We do the same,
a similar type thing in the U S to make sure that you're sending healthy
astronauts,
you have that two week period to make sure that nothing's going to pop up and
then hopefully anybody that launches won't be carrying anything up with them.
Looking up at the planet from the ISS,
everything looks, I guess, beautiful. And as it always looks,
and then you get these news, um, about what's happening,
uh, um, that there is a pandemic.
It wasn't possible for you to fully, uh,
understand what was happening.
First of all, like you say,
I'm looking out the window and I'm seeing this earth that is equally as stunning
and beautiful in every way as it was before that.
And then to be watching the news to be talking to our loved ones at home and
seeing this whole situation unfold,
it was a little bit difficult for us to believe that it was happening because we
were still very busy in the earth beneath us,
was coming to this almost grinding hall.
But we were still up there doing our same job every day,
being very busy with the experiments, with the space station, maintenance,
everything that we were doing.
And it was very strange to think we're only three humans right now of the
7.5 billion humans on earth.
We are only three of us that are not affected by this right now.
So we heard the stories we saw what was happening,
but it was difficult to feel like it was reality.
It felt a little bit surreal for us to be witnessing it up from up there.
You became a part of a historic space walk.
The first bake is basically what you did.
You did many spaces from home to two or three, right? I did three. Yep. Yeah.
Uh, but the first one was historic because it was the first all female it's
Facebook, right?
It was, yes. I mean, there have been many other women, of course,
that I'd have done spacewalks, but never two women at the same time.
And of course it did mean a lot to a lot of people on earth.
And that was something that was actually quite overwhelming for me. I,
I was really surprised by the magnitude of the response that we
were getting from the ground.
We received so many messages from young girls or from really any young person
with a dream or from adults as well saying how much of a difference it made to
them and how inspired it made them. And that,
that the magnitude of that was certainly not lost on us.
We felt so privileged to have that extraordinary opportunity.
Can you, can you, even though it is, uh, an old females Bezos,
can you take me with you?
It was definitely the highlight. I would say of my mission.
I look at those three spacewalks as that was something I wish I could have done
even more have we were incredibly fortunate to have done so many in expedition
61, which was the first four months of my mission.
We did nine spacewalks in that period. And that is really much more than normal.
Normally in one mission like that you'll have zero one or maybe two spacewalks.
And we had nine just given the circumstances. And of course, you know,
being one of those being the first all-female spacewalk,
and it was just such an amazing experience, something that you never forget,
and the hatch opens and you come outside and I looked down and I could see my
boots and then nothing else, but the earth below.
And it was just so extraordinary and seeing the views that we have from the
space station at the window of our, of course, incredible,
but it looked even a little bit more crisp and the colors even looked a little
bit more intense when you're only looking through the, through the thin visor,
no nothing is separating you from the vacuum of space,
except for this thin visor.
And you're in this mini little self-contained spacecraft of your own, really.
And that is just of course, a very intense experience.
I wish that during our spacewalks,
we had more time to really just appreciate that and to look at the earth and
look around.
But the truth is that we're so busy getting the task done that we need to do.
And it's really does.
It's completely all consuming of your concentration and your focus because
it is exhausting physically and mentally in order to work in that space suit.
So very quickly you're focused on the task at hand, but.
Have it, uh, I mean, did, did it all, did it all go smooth, uh, for,
for the, both of you or do you.
It did. It did that first spacewalk. We were incredibly lucky.
Everything worked out.
It was just one of those days where nothing went wrong and that's, you know,
that's actually not normal. Normally there's something you didn't expect.
And this is hardware that's left out there for years.
So it's undergone various thermal cycles.
So sometimes bolts don't cooperate or you don't know exactly what to expect from
the hardware. We, everything went really, really well on that first spacewalk.
What about Dale? The two, yeah, the, the other two,
we actually did have some unexpected things happen.
And that was really interesting for us because I think that's when your training
really kicks in, when you have an unanticipated situation,
you have to be able to react to it. And that we had two instances,
one on the second space walk, there was a moment at the very,
towards the very beginning of the spacewalk where suddenly, you know,
Christina and I were separated by several feet.
And I was actually on the other side of this, of this one pallet.
And she suddenly said, I, you know, I think there's something wrong.
I think that my, my lights have become dislodged on the top of the space suit.
We have a video camera and lights and that's not something that's supposed to
come off outside. And so hers had become detached and I look over,
so I make my way over to her and I see it just dangling by one
electrical connection and it's floating away from her.
And so we first attempted to try to put it back on. Um,
but it actually is impossible to do that with all the men.
There are some really intricate mechanisms that you need to do.
So to be able to do that with gloved hands was actually impossible.
So what they, but what they had me do was actually detach it from that cable.
So I did have to, you know, very carefully remove this cable. And that was,
you know, obviously quite stressful, um,
given this was only my second spacewalk and I'm trying to do something that
we're not even supposed to be able to do with gloves, but we managed to do that.
And so Christina conducted the rest of that spacewalk essentially without
lights, which was fine in when we had the sun shining. But of course every,
you know, 45 minutes or so. So we're in complete darkness. Uh,
it was an interesting experience for sure.
Uh, you, you, uh, you're both, uh,
Americans and Russians up there. Uh,
are there any no-go topics when you,
when you just have your evening chit chats?
Yeah, not really. And you know,
of course we're more diverse than just Americans and Russians.
We also had an Italian crew member on board with us,
and at other times during the mission,
we have Japanese and Canadian crew members too.
And I think that really those sort of political issues though, of course,
they're incredibly important for everybody on the ground.
We really don't think that way when we're in space, you know,
we are up there operating as one crew. And I think it's easy,
very easy for us to have that perspective when we look down on the planet and we
don't see those geopolitical man-made and we know that we really, you know,
it's just kind of the response that I felt when having that perspective in
relation to COVID-19 as well. The looking down at the planet from up there,
it is very easy for us to see that we are all in this together,
that we really are all one humans. And I think that's how we feel as a crew.
You know, I, I would say, yeah, you're probably right.
We don't directly bring up those topics about our political situations on the
ground, but I don't think it's, you know, it's not awkward.
It's not really uncomfortable. We're not avoiding anything.
It's just not really something that we're focused on. How.
Much of Sweden did you bring up?
I had, uh, a really large Swedish flag. I had a, um, um,
a banner from [inaudible] and I had something from Vesta Ross,
which is where my grandmother is from where my mother was from.
And a few other things. I Pippi Longstocking book.
So peppy now finally she's been in space.
Absolutely. I mean,
I think if any female we're going to be the right Swedish female to be in space
it's pippy. Right.
Indeed. Absolutely. Um, do you,
I mean, do you, do you miss it, do you want to go back?
Yes, I would go tomorrow if I could.
W w w why is that? What, what do you miss the most?
I think, you know,
what I've been saying since I came back is gravity is overrated and it is just
this,
the feeling of floating and the views looking down at the planet and just
being part of all of that.
It was really so powerful and I knew it at the time.
I actually did want to stay longer. Not, not everybody feels that way.
There are quite a few people that I would say coming to the end of their
approximately six month mission. They're usually ready to go back for me.
I would have rather had a longer mission. And I think,
especially given the situation when all of the current current situation on the
ground was happening, of course, that made it slightly even slightly more,
less desirable to return given the situation that we're turning to after being
in isolation for so many months, and then thinking, okay,
now we're going to go back to earth and be in more isolation. And personally,
I think it's much more isolating and confining down here in this present
situation than it is on the space station, because that's, well,
that's just part of our mission, right?
We know there's a very good reason why we're isolated because we are in a
spacecraft that we need a life support system for.
We cannot survive in the vacuum of space, you know,
without a space suit or without all of the luxuries of the space station that we
have and because everything else is so extraordinary,
all of the experiences that we're having are so intense, you know,
I think that the isolation is just really part of that. You're expecting it.
That's just part of the nominal environment now on earth,
our society isn't built for that, right? We're not, are we,
we are not designed to be home alone, sitting inside,
not interacting with other humans, you know,
not going out and experiencing the world around us. So I think that the,
the difference there is that it's, that's just not the way our society is built.
And so to me, it really feels much more isolated here to know that they're all,
there are all those things that I could be doing, you know, I could be out,
you know, hiking in the forest. Uh, but I can't do those things right now.
So I think that makes it a little bit more difficult. You have, um.
I, I know in, in, in high school, uh,
you said that your future plan was to,
to go for a space walk now that you, you did that.
What, what are your future plans?
I don't know. That's a good question.
I've wondered a lot about what this would feel like having fulfilled that goal
of being in space of making those spacewalks and now, what am I going to do now?
What's next? So I don't know. I, I think, you know, for me, of course,
I'm really, I think it's interesting.
I've actually thought more about when I can go back to space than I have about
integrating into life down on earth. I,
so the chance to go back is of course an incredible draw.
And hopefully that will happen for me again at NASA. And it depends on,
you know,
what I'm kind of back in line now waiting to get assigned for another mission.
So it would be great to have another mission, whether that be on a,
on a different vehicle to the space station again,
or maybe part of the Artemis missions,
it would be an amazing experience to be part of those Artemis missions,
go into the moon. And again, that would be, that would be my choice,
but I'm not really in control of those decisions.
Uh, I won't be surprised if that happens. Jessica,
thank you so much for taking the time.
Well, I text them again. They are all electives. [inaudible] dog. Uh,
you hope us, you hope us. Um,
Ian's not.
You enjoyed the clip for more interesting conversations, please hit subscribe.